all right the lion's at seven the lion's
at seven
that one fascinates me you mentioned the
possibility they could trade down they
got jared goff and
i mean
all due respect you know what follows
all due respect is jared goff
i i i i love this pic because i have no
idea what the lions are going to do in
part because i don't know who's making
the call peter you got a lot of chefs in
that kitchen you got chris spielman you
got rod wood who supposedly wasn't going
to be involved in football and is very
involved in football you got dan
campbell you got brad holmes
everybody but the owner has a spoon in
the stew here i i can't wait to see what
they do because i have no idea what it's
going to be
[Music]
look
mike as you start to look at this draft
the one thing that you see
when you start to get into
sort of the netherworld of you know
outside the very top
and you look at the detroit lions so the
lions
are in a decent space
in this draft you know they've got three
or four picks basically in the top 100
their fourth pick is number 101.
and
i think that brad holmes
after having been in los angeles after
having been a scouting director
and looking at the college players in
this draft has a very confident feel
about what he wants
out of this crop
and i think he likes this crop
and it really sort of blends in to the
needs of the detroit lions receiver
offensive line are two very big needs
and there are some corners in the second
round that they could go get if need be
i really think they would like to trade
out if they stay
i would expect
that they would do one of two things
that they would either take
waddle or smith whichever receiver is
left
or that they'd take the second
they take one of the two tackles because
clearly that offensive line is something
that has never gotten fixed in detroit
and i'm just fascinated by their entire
draft this year we know dan campbell is
looking for badass his kneecap biters
and and the 49ers have done a great job
of finding those guys who can flip that
switch immediately and doesn't matter if
you're not practicing tackling it
doesn't matter if you're not practicing
in pads they're going to go out there
and they're ready to go that's how
they're built
i think they're going to be looking for
guys like that generally but if justin
fields is sitting there at seven that
ohio state connection of spielman to
fields i i just i wonder how strong that
draw is going to be because
spielman probably is in position to get
a lot more information about fields than
anyone else who's evaluating fields
right now other than maybe urban meyer
and meyer's already locked in on
lawrence we mentioned the panthers
they've got sam darnold
they've yet to officially pick up the
option they've said they're going to
it would be a a 20 million gamble
they've already made a 33 million gamble
on teddy bridgewater that they're ready
to walk away from could they really take
a quarterback at number eight peter
i think they could um
i think this is a little ballet dance
that they're doing because they've got
to move bridgewater
i hear denver is interested in
bridgewater um and so they've got to
move bridgewater
and
they i think they could take a
quarterback here mike i don't i don't
think they will necessarily but this is
one of the pivot points of the draft
that i think they look at and they see
a large number
of options that they like but
i'll just tell you this mike
so
you know a couple of weeks ago you
probably saw that matt rule the coach of
the panthers
went down and spent some time with jimmy
johnson down in isla murada where jimmy
lives
and
clearly matt rule
you know is a sponge
and i know i've heard people talk about
him and and so he's obviously asking
jimmy
about a lot of things because jimmy
controlled drafts
and i'll just tell you the one thing
that is that sort of
sits in the craw and eats at
scott fitter the general manager and
matt rule
over the last eight years the panthers
have have averaged 6.2 draft picks per
year
and the average number of nfl draft
picks over that time is eight point one
because of compe per team because of
compensatory picks
so
i think the panthers look at basically
they've been dealing with a talent
shortfall
they traded three picks for sam darnold
they
want to come out of this draft with more
draft capital what better way to do that
than to trade down to the patriots at 15
let the patriots come up and get a
quarterback they get a one from next
year and let's say an extra three this
year
and they're happy
ben fisher of sports business journal
pointed out yesterday that the very
excellent all or nothing series on
amazon that would follow a team around
for a full season
no addition this year because of the
pandemic and it may be done for good and
that's unfortunate because i learned a
lot about david tepper in
a short scene in the final episode and
i've mentioned this before but he made
it clear coach gm and quarterback are
the things that allow you to skew eight
and eight into a winning team the league
set up to be eight and eight and you if
you have coach gm and quarterback you go
in the other direction and i i think
they are willingly
taking their shots at a guy that could
be their their franchise quarterback
they tried it with teddy bridgewater 33
million dollars they will have spent
didn't work we tried it didn't work now
sam darnold we're going to try it
maybe to work maybe it won't
but if that window opens if the board
falls in a way where one of the guys
they thought they weren't going to have
a shot at is there that's when you
really have to wonder peter whether
tepper
gets involved and we know these owners
find a way to get involved and i think
tepper would be closer to the jerry
jones
end of the spectrum than the owner who
has truly nothing to do with the team
i i you gotta you just gotta wonder what
pepper's gonna say
if lancer field somehow trickle through
to eight
well just remember back in 2016 when
jerry jones desperately and i mean
desperately wanted paxton lynch at the
end of the first round of that draft
and stephen jones spent 70 minutes 7-0
minutes on the phone calling everybody
in the nfl in their path you know we
make a trade with us we do this we do
that and they were offering basically
their second round pick and their fourth
at the top of the fourth round and
everybody that wasn't enough it wasn't
enough and seattle finally got a better
deal you know they wanted the second and
third from dallas and seattle finally
got the deal they wanted from denver
denver took paxton lynch and it's you
know be careful what you wish for
obviously in retrospect
but
that was a moment where i learned
something about jerry jones and
and i don't know if this relates to
david tepper but i'm going to tell you
what i learned about jerry jones in that
way is he could have big-footed will
mcclay and tom saskowski and stephen
jones and jason garrett
and he could have said
bleep it
we are making this trade
and we're moving up and we're getting
paxton lynch but you know what mike
he was miserable
but he didn't overrule the football
people
and so that's what i think that
especially
when scott federer is just there he just
got there i just can't envision
a general manager being told in his
first major decision
you know since he's been on the job
i can't imagine the owner coming in and
saying hey
i know you got this offer with the
patriots to move down or whatever
but
we're taking trey lance
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports